[Música]
en directo a vamos hasta buenos aires
con nuestro corresponsal natalia cos hoy
para hablar sobre el reporte del
instituto nacional de estadísticas y
censos que sitúa la inflación a
interanual en agosto en 78 5% la mayor
tasa registrada en 30 años pero los
expertos prevén que la cifra anual
podría llegar al 100 por ciento para
finales de este año natalio muy buenas
noches tienen un impacto los más
recientes acuerdos con el fmi en los
datos inflacionarios o hay otro motivo
que está impulsando el alza de los
precios
los acuerdos y las negociaciones con el
fondo monetario internacional no es que
tengan un impacto directo y automático
sobre la inflación en argentina pre
cierto que las medidas acordadas con el
organismo internacional tienen que ver
entre otras cosas con reducir y
controlar la inflación en argentina el
ministro sergio massa que estuvo en eeuu
reuniéndose con el fondo monetario
internacional ha implementado algunas de
estas medidas por ejemplo la de reducir
la emisión monetaria el ajuste y el
control del gasto público y también
intentar otorgar y ofrecer tasas de
interés positivas para que los
ahorristas como una forma de capturar
dinero del circulante y buscar cerrar
también la brecha entre el dólar oficial
y el dólar libre que es muchísimo más
alto y también tiene un impacto además
de tratar de controlar los precios de
algunos productos masivos a través de
planes como precios cuidados con las
grandes empresas porque bueno todos
estos son elementos que si están fuera
de control afectan a la inflación y
tienen un efecto sobre los precios de
incremento agosto tuvo un 7 por ciento
de inflación mensual ligeramente menor
que el 7,4 por ciento de julio el
ministro más había dicho cuando asumió
en agosto que julio y agosto iban a ser
los meses más difíciles veremos que a
partir de ahora comienza a achicarse
aunque sea ligeramente la inflación que
ha sido muy grande ha tenido un impacto
muy grande sobre la población natal yo
lo mencionábamos hace un momento los
analistas prevén que la inflación
anualizada llegue al 100 por ciento para
finales de este año qué consecuencias
tendría esto a nivel social
bueno es muy fuerte la consecuencia de
la inflación aún cuando algunos salarios
pueden ir recuperando sea aquí
especialmente los sectores formales que
están dentro de sindicatos con gran
capacidad de negociación pueden ir
haciendo actualizaciones pero aún en ese
caso que es el mejor de los casos esas
actualizaciones quedan por detrás de la
inflación ni hablar sindicatos con menos
capacidad de negociación y los grandes
sectores de la población que se
encuentran en la economía informal o que
dependen de la asistencia del estado
pensemos que hay aumentos hasta ahora en
el último año en la ropa y calzado de
109 por ciento en alimentos y bebidas un
sector clave del 80 por ciento en el
último año bueno en restaurantes y en
hoteles que es un rubro que tiene
impacto en argentina también
97,5 pero me parece que el del alimento
es clave y el de las prendas de vestir
también si nos acercamos en torno al 100
por ciento fin de año que es lo que
prevé en la mayoría de las consultoras y
los salarios no se acercan evidentemente
es un impacto al bolsillo de la
población y eso también nos da cuenta de
por qué
está siendo difícil de controlar a pesar
de que la actividad económica se había
estado recuperando tenemos un dato de
muchos trabajadores que están debajo de
la línea de la pobreza y eso es algo que
da cuenta del impacto entre otras cosas
de la inflación en argentina